البرهان وحميدتي جنرالاني جنح الى الحرب
بعد ان كان السودان قاب قوسين او ادناه من
توقيع اتفاق تاريخي العربيه جمعت البرهان
وحميدتي على شاشتها في حوار غير مباشر
بينهما في مقابلتين خاصتين من بدا الحرب
من يسيطر على العاصمه وما ابرز اماكن وجود
قوات كل طرف
الجيش على مطار الخرطوم في اشكاليه ومطار
نياله في اشكاليه نعم هنالك وجود لمجموعات
كثيره جدا من هذه القوات وسط
الاحياء
المهندسين
اين يوجد البرهان وحميتي انا موجود في
هيئه قياده القوات المسلحه
ومضارحه ولن ابارحها هذه هي مهنتي وهذا
شرفي لن اخرج الا محمولا على
من خلق الهدنه اي هدنه اعلنت اصلا ما في
حتى ابتدات
القوات الطرف الاخر غير مسيطر عليها وهي
منتشره في مناطق مختلفه من الحياه السكنيه
من اختار الحرب عوض السلام اليوم احنا
قلنا موجودين في مق
راتنا نريد ان نخرج نخرج الى خارج دائره
الدفاع
من يستهدف المستشفيات والبعثات الاجنبيه
كيف ستنتهي المعركه
لن تعلم
هذه الحرب انا اقول ان هذه الحرب ليس فيها
كاسد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات